[Music]
the Smurfs
this movie is directed by Raja Gosnell
check out the filmography for this guy
he directed home alone three never been
kissed Big Momma's House scooby doo one
and two yours mine and ours and Beverly
Hills Chihuahua now he directed The
Smurfs the Smurfs is a big film
adaptation of the original cartoon where
these little blue things live in their
own little world and they're running
from this wizard Gargamel or whatever
his name is played by Hank Azaria and
they get somehow zapped into New York
City of course by some portal and they
have a big adventure in New York City
and meet Neil Patrick Harris and his
expecting life and they have a wonderful
life-changing experience
I honestly have no idea how to start
saying this this is one of the worst
movies I've ever seen in my life
I went to this movie thinking it's
probably not going to be the best movie
and I mean it blew me away
it it literally blew me away how bad
this movie is it is so so bad I mean it
is it's terrible it I can't even I have
no words to describe how bad this movie
is and overs gonna ask is it worse than
Dragonball Evolution is it worse than
The Last Airbender yes it's worse than
The Last Airbender
oh yeah it's worse than The Last
Airbender Dragonball Evolution is my
least fair movie of all time
it's one of the only movies I ever gave
zero stars I gave it no stars whatsoever
I don't know if it's that bad but it's
one of the things that really started to
get on my nerves to the point at the
very beginning the first time it
happened I went oh my gosh that's so
stupid
but then they kept doing it over and
over again they use the word Smurf for
everything they say well that's a Smurfs
in good and shirt you got on
that's a Smurfs an outfit
you smurfin ruined that Smurf for us I
mean I'm not even kidding it's
throughout the entire movie Neil Patrick
Harris is a talented actor Hank Azaria
is a talented comedian but they're
completely wasted I mean they got
nothing to do they're stuck making
little faces and smiling and with these
little CGI things that aren't even there
and just trying to appeal to some form
of demographic and that's the other
problem this movies demographic is
completely mixed up because it's
obviously aimed at children however
there's an entire subplot involving Neil
Patrick Harris his job where he works
this advertising agency that the kids
are 100% not gonna care about and then
the childish side of the film with all
the Smurfs jokes in the Smurfs humor and
everything the kids very young kids may
like like five and under
the adults are gonna hate and it just it
has no demographic it just completely
mixes up the entire what it's supposed
to be I mean it's all over the place
there's not one age group that it's
gonna 100% like this movie it's just so
I don't understand why do these movies
get made the product placement out of
this world I mean there's a scene where
the camera does like a 360 revolving
spin of Times Square where they try to
get every single possible huge product
of today in that shot it is atrociously
obvious this film is 100% of cash-grab
and I don't even understand it because
the movie is so bad it's not gonna make
any money at all it's opening with Crazy
Stupid Love and Cowboys and Aliens two
great movies that I really enjoyed and
they're just gonna crush it another
thing that is so dumb is the Smurfs
apparently have no idea what the human
world is never been there this random
poor that was created after the Papa
Smurf saw a vision of the future that
showed him everything that was going to
happen including the finale of the film
I'm going to avoid talking about that
and move on to what I was about to say
they've never been to the human world
and yet they know all of these human
things they know all these jokes that
humans make an inhuman terminology and
all these things that apparently they've
never known about they stumble upon some
book library where they find a comic
book with the Smurfs animation but
apparently the Smurfs cartoon doesn't
exist
in this world because they googled
Smurfs and they never found anything
about the cartoons but they found a
cartoon book with them some of the
cartoon book tells them how to get
back some magical spell I mean it's so
bad it's so freakin bad this movie is
just I hate it I was sitting there
begging for it to end and I stayed until
the end and then I just ran out of that
theater like my butt was on fire I mean
oh gosh this movie's terrible I
literally did not laugh once during this
movie I mean there is nothing they keep
singing a stinking lalala song over and
over again the funny thing to me isn't
the first time that a character does it
they go wow that's pretty annoying you
should probably stop doing that it's
pretty annoying they're like no it's
great and they keep doing it over and
over again film itself acknowledged how
annoying it is it's like they took the
last airbender Dragonball Evolution
added it together and threw in every
crappy children's movie ever made
somehow came out with some mixed up
gigantic horrible movie that I just want
to burn every copy of there is literally
not one redeeming quality of it and
that's why I'm gonna give the Smurfs 0
out of 4 stars
nothing nothing please go see Cowboys
and Aliens are crazy stupid love they're
too great fun movies that are
considerably better than this piece of
absolute crap The Smurfs is honestly one
of the worst movies I've ever seen in my
entire life by far the worst movie of
the year I hated literally everything
about it the movie is an absolute
atrocity that should not exist
please don't secrets Wow it's bad if
you've liked this review please
subscribe my channel and get stockman
eyes
[Music]